r cette militante pour le droit des
femmes vous êtes fondatrice goulding
pour aider les femmes à se sentir mieux
et bravo donc des japon pour ce que vous
faites
juliette vous avez poussé un coup de
gueule sur l' affaire polanski dans une
vidéo publiée sur twitter on va voir on
va revoir votre vidéo et c'est vrai que
vous ça vous fait mal au coeur les gens
qui soutiennent romane pour lens qui ça
vous dérange énormément
enfin qui dit voilà on va regarder vous
allez nous dire pourquoi vous dites
qu'il devrait devriez même pas à y avoir
de polémique concernant oman polanski
pour vous déjà ça c'est complètement fou
regarde marche
je voudrais agir sur la polémique
comment ce qui est anti pédophilie ou
pro pédophilie aux le choix elle doit
d'ailleurs ça me rappelle ce job de
danseuses oui je me suis à moitié fait
agresser sexuellement et quand j'en ai
parlé au chorégraphe mais aussi est
vachement l'air d'hésiter défendent les
droits des êtres humains qui me font
confiance ou la commission que je prends
sur eux au passage à pas facile là
encore chaud les dieux moi j'ai envie
d'avoir votre avis sur plein de choses
ce sera car juliette vraiment un jeu là
pour le domaine baptisé n'y a pas ce que
vous dites donc c'est vrai que voilà il
a du talent sa porte et sa porte les
gens à confusion
vous dites on se pose les mauvaises
questions nationales pour moi c'est ça
la polémique elle est simple ces pros
pédophilie ou anti pédophilie maintenant
effectivement la source de cette
polémique elle est bien plus profonde
que ça ce qui pousse les gens dans la
confusion
c'est que le gars est censé avoir du
talent je descends c'est parce que moi
j'ai jamais vu aucun de ceux fils
d'accord donc on se dit si le gars a du
talent c'est qui peut pas être si
mauvais que ça mais non ça veut dire que
c'est pas un banquier
il laisse pas son costume au placard
quand ils rentrent le soir n'ont
retourné à un artiste on est passionné
et quand on est passionné ans les 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
donc on peut pas dissocier à mon sens
l'homme de l'artiste cette fois qu'une
seule personne
vous prenez pas ce que isabelle voilà
c'est vrai que cette vidéo tourne
partout dirais que ce que vous avez à
répondre à juliette a dit ça alors pour
ce que j'ai compris par contre je trouve
que c'est une simplification de
tellement de choses d'abord à juger
quelqu'un et dire je n'ai vu aucun de
ses films ça me choque
mara ainsi par manque en jeu juste que
je fasse ça me dégoûte en fait à prix
bas mais c'est la vision d'un pédophile
sur des longs métrages et autant plus
que je suis comédienne que je suis
actrice je peux pas regarder ça parce
que pendant bien des eaux
c'est cautionner ça bien ça alors je
voulais juste isabelle pour vraiment
pour rush pas pour défendre juliette
mais moi j'étais avec un pote ce midi
voilà qu il a rien à voir il pas du tout
dans le milieu du cinéma tout ça il m'a
dit moi voilà je ne vais je n'irai
jamais voir un film de roman polanski
après il m'a dit chacun fait ce qu'il
veut mais voilà c'était son avis ou
alors oui chacun festival a effectué un
message au ministre était il était
nourri un légume julia talent qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez moi je comprends
je cautionne pas mais je comprends votre
carnet fusil j'ai un cerveau à jeun
l'esprit je suis capable de comprendre
et d'entendre ce que vous mais j'ai
encore rien je suis et je suis désolé on
va prendre dans le sens où pour vous
jacchus vous avez rien dit j'en attends
les images ici sont déjà cuites est un
bon film pour vous si on vous avait pas
dit jacques hull c'est un film de
polanski c'est un film sur
l'antisémitisme le film halo reach vous
seriez allé le voir
non c'est non si on ne parle que de ça
je le sais ça mais ce n'est pas dans ce
film de cet ehpad romane s'était battu
voilà néanmoins j'accuse
roman polanski qui réalise en film
s'appelle jacques hull est ce que vous
savez que celle inception du fait n'est
pas une phrase de polanski le j'accuse
bien sûr que si tu as bien tu as dû
répondre à la question s'il vous plaît
alors si c'est ehpad roma le bras est
recherché par interpol dans les cieux
juliette ci s'était pas réalisé par
roman polanski est ce que vous auriez
telle voie ça dépend
réalisé à quelqu'un et ça organisé par
n'importe qui je vois pas trop la tête
je sais pas je peux pas dire et si avec
des si on refait le monde